(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> IF HE WERE SPEAKING TO
SOMEONE WHO WANTED TO RAISE THE
CONFEDERATE FLAG, HE WOULD
PROBABLY START OFF BY SAYING
SOMETHING TO THE EFFECT OF, YOU
ARE SOME FUNNY, FUNNY PEOPLE.
FOR YOU IT'S ALWAYS SUMMERTIME
AND THE LIVIN' IS EASY.
YOUR MAMA'S RICH AND YOUR MAMA'S
GOT LOOKIN'.
YOU'RE A CONFEDERATE, A PROUD
SOUTHERN WHITE BOY.
YOUR BIBLE IN YOUR HAND AND A
SHOTGUN IN YOUR PICKUP TRUCK.
A SOUTHERN WHITE BOY, WITH THE
SHAME OF SLAVERY RUNNIN' THROUGH
YOUR VEINS.
YOU ARE A BIGOT.
I AM A BLACK MAN.
I HAVE WORKED AND SCRAPED FOR
EVERY INCH OF DIRT I WALK ON.
YOU CRIED YOURSELF TO SLEEP
'CAUSE LINCOLN HURT YOUR
FEELINGS.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
YOU BACKWOODS, SHEET-WEARING,
CROSS-BURNING, HONKY [ BLEEP ].
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
YOU LOSE THE WAR AND ALL YOU
WANT TO DO IS MAKE MY PEOPLE PAY
FOR IT.
YOU THINK YOU LOVE THIS COUNTRY.
WHAT YOU LOVE IS THAT CORRUPTION
OF THE RED, WHITE AND BLUE YOU
CALL VALOR.
WHAT YOU LOVE IS THE
SATISFACTION THAT MESS BRINGS
WHEN PEOPLE FEEL THEY NEED TO
GIVE THAT FLAG SOME CREDENCE.
LIKE IT STANDS FOR SOMETHING
MORE THAN HATE.
FIGHTING ABOUT WHETHER TO TEAR
IT DOWN FROM ATOP YOUR STATE
BUILDING OR NOT, YOU ARE A
BIGOT.
AND I AM DISAPPOINTED IN THE WAY
YOU TREAT MY COUNTRY.